met this new girl that's absolutely
incredible and she is in the process of
uh going through a separation and then a
divorce and just feeling some feelings
of I don't want to say shame but you
know uncertainty like I want to know how
to best support her me like who talk
about wanting to be together and I know
I you know truly care about her I know
she feels the same and you know just
looking for some guy and not how to move
forward with
that how honest can I be with
you I'm
ready so you're you're You' fallen for a
married
woman that's the yeah that's the truth
yeah
um the best advice I can give you just
guy to guy sitting across the table is
run as fast as you
can and I know you don't want to hear
that cuz she's incredible